الان الى القصه الاهم ربما بعد الزلزال
كيف يمكن ان نبني المباني التي ستحمين
فللعلماء يتوقعون ولا الناس يستعدون وحدهم
المهندسون يهندسون ولنا في اليابان كل
الامثله التي نحتاجها فمبان اليابان
المرنه ساعدت على مقاومه زلازل كارثيه هذا
المبنى مثلا في اليابان يستخدم تقنيه
العزم كيف يحصل ذلك ببساطه يعزل هيكل
البناء عن قاعدته الاساسيه عن طريق وضع
عوازل هذه العوازل تمتص الصدمه لحظه وقوع
الزلزال نسيم طبقات المطاطيه عندما يحصل
الزلزال يتحرك المبذله للامام والخلف لكنه
يظل مستقيما بالتالي هذه التقنيه هي
مثاليه لناطحات السحاب وما اكثرها في
طوكيو ننتقل معكم الى هذا المبدا تشينجوكو
تسوي في اليابان وهو احد اشهر الابنيه في
طوكيو هذا ما هو يستخدم تقنيه لافته جدا
وهي تعرف بتندول الساعه الذي يتحرك يمينا
يسارا تخيلوا مثلا بندولا عملاقا من
المعدن يزن مئات الاطنان ويوضع في اعلى
المبنى هذا المبنى الشهير يمتص الصدمه
بالتحرك بعكس تارجح المبنى الان ننتقل
معكم ايضا الى تكنولوجيا المفضله لناطحات
السحاب هذه المره ولكنها الاعلى تكلفه في
اليابان هي تقنيه توضع في قاعده المبنى
اذا ما تحدثنا عن الاسفل قاعده المبنى على
طبقات اما من الرصاص او الفولاذ او المطاط
السميك هذا التصميم هو يساعد اساسات
المبنى بالتحرك وايضا تقليل قوه الزلزال
سواء على الطوابق العليا هي طبعا مستخدمه
في برج طوكيوس كايتري وهو ثالث اطول مبنى
في العالم نذهب معكم الى التقنيه الاحدث
في الرفع هذا المنزل مثلا هو مجهز بك
الزلازل في حال تم تسجيل هزه يتم رفع
المبنى بالاعتماد على ضاغط هواء هذا
الضاغط حتى ثلاثه سم من الارض ويعود بعدها
الى الارض بمجرد استقرار الصفائح هناك